Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P The anti-vaxxers have
immediately swarmed over what happened on
the field on Monday, where football player
DeMar Hamlin suffered a cardiac arrest. And
here is, here is a call about exactly that.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, this is Jennifer from
the Philadelphia suburb. Yes. Calling about
something that I've seen circulating around the
Internet over the past few days since the Tamar
Hamlin medical scare earlier this week. The safety
from the Buffalo Bills who had a cardiac arrest
in certain areas of experience. This flight made
special media. There is attribution that it's
because of COVID vaccine rather than the fact
that a six foot four, £220 opponent struck him
in the chest, running full force. Right. I am a
medical doctor. I can tell you that one of those
causes is far more likely. And I think it has
more to do with the one that's going to knock
you on your back rather than being a band Band-Aid
on your deltoid. However, I don't think you need
ten years of post-graduate training to know that.
Speaker 1: I think yeah. And again, we do not even
know the vaccination status of DeMar Hamlin, or at
least we didn't as of yesterday when I last read
about this. And there are so many leaps in logic
that are being made here that it is really it's
truly a scary thing that these folks for whom
again, they've got a hammer, which is vaccines
are bad, that's their hammer. So everything is a
nail. Someone gets COVID. Oh, it's because of the
vaccine. Someone has a heart attack. It's because
of the vaccine. Someone dies, it's because of the
vaccine. Everything is the vaccine because all
they've got is a hammer. And it's a really sad
situation we've got and and a destructive one,
I should add. Great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about something interesting going
on with millennials in politics. Southwest
Airlines involved in a controversy. A MAGA hat
wearing teacher has been, in a sense, vindicated
legally. All of it is on the bonus show today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah. Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves as bat.
Speaker 1: Sign up at join Pacman
Icon and we will see you then.